>> Greg: IN NASHVILLE,
BETO O'ROURKE TOLD IMMIGRANTS
THAT OUR COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON
WHITE SUPREMACY, SLAVERY, AND
OPPRESSION.
OTHER THAN THAT, WE ARE AWESOME.
>> THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON
WHITE SUPREMACY.
AND EVERY SINGLE INSTITUTION AND
STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COUNTRY STILL REFLECTS THE
LEGACY OF SLAVERY AND
SEGREGATION AND JIM CROW AND
SUPPRESSION, EVEN IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> Greg: RIGHT FROM THE WOMB,
WE ARE ALL RACIST.
IT'S THE NEW ORIGINAL SIN,
ACCORDING TO SLENDER MAN.
BETO'S EFFORTS TO SOW DIVISION
ONLY EXPAND.
HE'S LIKE A BITTER DIVORCED
HUSBAND TRASHING THE EX-WIFE.
IF HE CAN'T BE HAPPY, NO ONE
CAN.
IT USED TO BE THE POLITICIANS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND A NUMBER
OF TOOLS AT THEIR DISPOSAL, NOT
BETO.
HE IS THE TOOL.
TALK ABOUT A BLUNT OBJECT.
HIS ONLY FUNCTION IS TO CREATE
VICTIMS OUT OF BROWN AND BLACK
AMERICANS THAT THEY MIGHT LOOK
TO HIM, THE GREAT WHITE
SCARECROW, AS HER SAVIOR.
NOW HIS TRUE CONFIDENCE IS
EXPOSED AS A FARCE.
FOR SO LONG HIS FAILURES WERE
PROPPED UP BY A BOTTOMLESS
SPOUSAL INCOME AND ASSISTED BY
"VANITY FAIR" COVER THIS BONE ON
HIM BY A PALE LIBERAL ENAMORED
HE LOOKED JUST LIKE THEM.
HE WAS WHITE, PATRONIZING,
SLICK, AND ELITIST.
HE IS SO WHITE, WONDER BREAD
COULD SUE FOR PLAGIARISM.
HE IS REDUCED TO PLAYING FOR
RADICAL SCRAPS, DANCING TO FIGHT
SONGS IN SAFE SPACES, A WINDUP
TOY.
HE WILL SAY ANYTHING.
SO NOW WE ARE ALL RACIST BY
BIRTH, HE SHOUTS, LIKE A
HOPELESS LONELY SLOB AT LAST
CALL DESPERATE FOR A PHONE
NUMBER.
I WOULD SAY GO HOME, YOU'RE
DRUNK.
BUT HE MIGHT DRIVE.
I WONDER IF I WAS NOT MEAN
ENOUGH.
>> Dagen: MORE MEAN.
>> Greg: WHO THOUGHT THIS GUY
HAD ANY POTENTIAL?
ERIC SWALWELL LOOKS LIKE
CHURCHILL COMPARED TO THIS GUY.
>> Dagen: INDEED AND HE IS
BETTER LOOKING.
HE'S GOING TO FIGHT RACIAL
INEQUALITY IN THIS COUNTRY
STARTING WITH A "VANITY FAIR"
COVER AND THE FOLLOW-UP WAS THE
STORY IN THE NEW YORKER WHICH
BASICALLY NO ONE READS AND JUST
TELLS EVERYBODY ELSE THEY READ
IT.
CAN BETO BOUNCE BACK?
YOU CAN'T PRACTICE IDENTITY
POLITICS IF YOU HAVE NO PERSONAL
IDENTITY.
YOU CAN SEE THE THOUGHT BUBBLE
OVER HIS HEAD.
WHEN AM I GOING TO DO WHEN I'M
DONE WITH THIS?
MAYBE I WILL BECOME A DENTIST.
MAYBE I WILL LEARN HOW TO EAT
USE ALL GLOOM AND MAKE ALPACA
THROWS.
>> Greg: MIGHT CALL IT WOKE
SHRINKAGE.
IF YOU CONTENDER TO SMEAR
EVERYBODY AS OPPRESSORS, THE
UNION NARROWED THE PARTY INTO AN
NO ONE IS AROUND.
I CALL IT WOKE SHRINKAGE.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEVER.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
SAYING THAT IT SORT OF POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY HE IS SAYING AND HE
WAS TRYING TO IMPACT REJUVENATE
HIS CANDIDACY WHICH IS WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING THE NEW YORKER PIECE
WAS ABOUT.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY DEBATE THAT
WHAT HE SAID IS TRUE.
>> Greg: YES THERE IS.
OUR COUNTRY WAS NOT FOUNDED ON
WHITE SUPREMACY.
I WOULD DISAGREE.
>> Juan: I WOULDN'T BECAUSE I
WOULD SAY THE FOUNDERS RESERVE
THE VOTING FRANCHISE FOR
LANDOWNING WHITE MALES.
THAT WAS IT.
DAGEN AND DANA COULDN'T VOTE.
>> Jesse: WAS IT FOUNDED ON
SEXISM?
>> Juan: YEAH.
>> Jesse: PILE IT ALL ON.
>> Juan: I'M NOT PILING IT ON.
TO SAY IT'S HISTORICAL FACT, I'M
SAYING IT'S THE FACT.
>> Jesse: BARACK OBAMA DIDN'T
EVEN SAY THAT ABOUT OUR COUNTRY.
HE SAID THE MOST BEAUTIFUL,
INSPIRING THINGS ABOUT THIS
NATION'S FOUNDING.
HE DIDN'T GET CLOSE TO WHAT YOU
SAID OR BETO O'ROURKE.
ANY PERSON IS GOING TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THIS COUNTRY NEVER
WOULD SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Juan: ANYBODY WHO KNOWS
AMERICAN HISTORY WOULD SAY
THAT'S REALITY.
THE QUESTION IS.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY AGREES WITH THAT.
>> Juan: HOW CAN YOU DISAGREE
WITH THE IDEA THAT THE FOUNDING
FATHERS SAID YOU'VE GOT TO BE A
LANDOWNING WHITE MALE.
>> Jesse: JUST BECAUSE
SOMETHING HAPPENED AT THE TIME
DOESN'T DEFINE THE FOUNDING.
>> Juan: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
>> Jesse: JUST BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAD SLAVES DURING THE FOUNDING
DOESN'T MEAN WE ARE FOUNDED ON
SLAVERY IN WHITE SUPREMACY IS
ON.
>> Juan: I THINK THE FACT OF
OUR AMERICAN --
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T DEFINE
THE FOUNDING.
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH THIS
POINT.
THE LEFT SEES THIS AND I THINK
BETO O'ROURKE IS REFLECTING IT,
HE SAYS LET'S FIX IT.
LET'S DO SOMETHING.
I THINK THEY ARE RIGHT, LIKE
YOU, REFUSES TO EVEN SAY YOU
KNOW IT, IT'S PART OF THE
ORIGINAL --
>> Jesse: I ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
WAS SLAVERY.
I ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WOMEN OR
BLACK AMERICANS DIDN'T HAVE
CERTAIN RIGHTS.
BUT WE FOUGHT IN 600,000 PEOPLE
DIED IN THE CIVIL WAR TO
ERADICATE IT.
EVERY INSTITUTION IN THIS
COUNTRY IS RACIST?
THE MILITARY, THE MEDIA, THE
JUSTICE, THE CULTURE.
EVERYTHING IS RACIST?
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
>> Juan: THE MILITARY IS OUR
LEADING EXAMPLE OF DIVERSITY.
YOU'RE SAYING EVERY SINGLE --
>> Jesse: YOU'RE SAYING EVERY
SINGLE INSTITUTION IS RACIST?
>> Greg: KIDS, MY GOING TO
HAVE TO SEPARATE YOU TWO?
>> Dana: I'M GOING TO CHANGE
THE TOPIC.
>> Greg: JASPER?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: NO.
>> Juan: HE'S MY BROWN BROTHER
BROTHER.
>> Dana: I THINK BETO O'ROURKE
IS THE ONLY ONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW
HIS CAMPAIGN IS OVER.
>> Greg: HE IS LIKE BRUCE
WILLIS IN "THE SIXTH SENSE."
I DON'T WANT TO SPOIL IT.
>> Dana: I'VE NEVER SEEN IT.
DOES THAT HAVE A WEIRD ENDING?
>> Greg: YOU DIDN'T SEE IT?
YOU DON'T REMEMBER THE ENDING OF
"THE SIXTH SENSE"?
IT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
MOVIE, THE ENDING.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE ENDING OF
THE TITANIC?
>> Dana: YES.
>> Greg: JAWS IS ABOUT A
SHARK.
>> Dana: IF HE KEEPS GOING,
IT'S GOING TO RUIN HIS FUTURE
POTENTIAL FOR OTHER OFFICES.
>> Greg: IN THE SIXTH SENSE,
WHAT HAPPENS IS --
I CAN'T SAY.
>> Juan: IT'S AN OLD MOVIE.
YOU CAN DO IT.
>> Greg: HE WAS DEAD ALL